okay opponent when t4 it's a five-minute
game I'll try to play this blocked be
known here this check benoni so I like
it it's interesting leads to very closed
positions but they are not easy to play
and black has got some some chances to
to put white in a very long maneuvering
game so Bishop age 6 i'm not sure what
what the point of the smooth okay I mean
it's not like I want to Castle anyway
please not in the near future so f3
hmm interesting okay so maybe he will
exchange the bishop I doubt it okay so
not my idea is to get this bishop on g5
and exchange it there so I retreat the
spin this night of course this is a very
close position and you can afford some
of those long winded maneuvers because
it's so close but need to be cautious
that white isn't able to suddenly open
the position and then you ask yourself
why don't have anything anything
developed okay so okay I take now and
try to exchange Queens if you place f4 I
kept Champlain 95 I get this night only
five and he doesn't have an ID ready to
challenge it so because they are not so
well placed here on c3 ng 3 to 5 45 so
if I from my F for now is there not a
move that I'm frightened so much of
yeah this was to be expected so should I
play just Knight f6 now yeah why not the
queen is not not badly placed here and I
might try h 5 h 49 h 5 the f4 square
would be would be great for night yeah
sure he wants to get some play himself
but this isn't so threatening at the
moment
you
yeah night on H on f4 is some
potentially dangerous so should I go
there yeah threatening on on g2 hmm how
does he even cover this
I have some some other ideas here Bishop
to h3 it's not possible at the moment of
course because after seven on seven
dollars and night but if I move this
night I might have those ideas also
Knight to f6 maybe yeah let's check his
moves um okay he want g3 I think I
shouldn't I should take first okay I
think he needs to recapture with the
pawn knight Knight takes looks like yeah
it's not playable rock edge too so what
now Queen h5 I think it's not working
not working at the moment the question
is rook h3 is this an idea threatening
rook takes he might have King f2 of
course i'm not sure that i have a good
move then
hmm yeah king of two of course so it
will happen most likely I'm missing
something here it looks like i should
have something but I don't see it
hmm kind of weird maybe I'm just just
blind here in this position it's
possible okay I'm King f2 is the move
that I'm I'm expecting and i'm not sure
what I should play on this I mean it's
really a questionable if he if he is
threatening to take here of course I
could play Bishop to h3 hear ya he takes
on f4 it's quincy to checkmate and I
might Emma just imagine stake here and
then look H 2 of course rook to h2 would
be would be great to to accomplish can I
take
okay come on I play it simple now maybe
this isn't the best here but it's
working I take here with check he needs
to recapture I take here and then i have
this check yet shouldn't be bad with the
rook on the second on the Sun no seventh
rank here and now i need more firepower
night h5 yeah maybe 9 h 5
yeah so take now yeah take if Yuri takes
Queen edge form check
and now i think i will need to I need a
second look at some point you cannot go
to the second rank with the King because
of night f form so it's a bit tied up at
the moment
hmm yeah my idea is to take you on a
four but maybe this isn't working really
hmm he just grabs everything
yeah he's got just rookie one
what this is also possible
I losses this would be super silly but
might happen
now you can play Quint XG three
unbelievably
yeah Rocky III maybe also sir not
winning this is really heartbreaking
yeah I have no move I have no move him
you can play Quincy phone and wins ah
terrible yeah I losing this is terrible
really i mean i'm pretty sure i have i
have simple win cm let's see yeah minus
seven bishop f1 here minus 16 yeah well
I thought of knew that 93 wasn't the
best move but it's not winning amazingly
computer only gives me a slight
advantage sure amazing chess is amazing
and this isn't flat out winning I can't
believe this yeah minus 2 or something
it gives me rook h3 now winsome why
you cannot I cannot play Brooke f3
because Africa h1 and Queen d2 I Winnie
form we are home I just a terrible game
look at three wins again look at three
wins again I really played the the only
kind of continuation that wins for wider
oh man man Tarawa all right some it was
quite interesting anyway out more like a
kind of help made problem finding the
only way how you should actually lose
the game rook h3 still win sets critic
regrade rook h3 Queen d2 Brooke h2 III
and it's all done yeah it's a deadly pin
word rook g1 just rupture one all right
yeah well it was interesting anyway I
mean I'm losing all those games here
Tori I hope it was instructive yeah
thanks for watching